we had a conversation with secretary of
minuchin and the president that there is
a a match loke was called the local
match for FEMA funding when the FEMA
does something the local government
should match that funding by 25 percent
I said to the president there is no way
New York can pay that match because we
don't have the funding period and it is
disproportionate to New York because
we've had such a much larger number of
cases than any other state in the United
States that it falls disproportionately
on New York which disproportionately is
dealing with this crisis in the first
place we get all the hardship and then
we get a bill because we had the
hardship makes absolutely no sense and
as a practical matter we couldn't pay it
anyway the president said he understood
and that he would work to waive the
local match secretary minuchin said he
understood secretary minuchin was very
supportive and I thank him for his
support and the president said that he
would he understood and that he would
take care of it and I believed that he
he will because he did understand it and
that's a big deal for the state of New
York again the the incongruity the state
that had the most pain and death should
get a bill because they endured pain and
death I mean it makes no sense so that
was a lot and it was complicated but
vitally important and the resolution was
good across the board we met not just
with the president but with members of
his team because a lot of this is
granular and detailed and if you don't
work out the details there was no
conceptual agreement right it has to be
on the details so people actually know
what we're agreeing to and it was on
that level so I thank all the people on
the president's team who made themselves
available and
work this through with us in detail and
it's a really positive positive
resolution any questions yes commitment
is to attempt and make all efforts to
double the number of tests that the
state is taking from 20,000 to 40,000
federal government will work on the
supply of tests and reagents from the
national manufacturers they'll take that
half of the equation we will take the
half of the equation that is working
with the labs in the state and getting
them to perform the tests but we need
the test kits from the manufacturers
national manufacturers need the supply
chain that's what the federal government
will be doing we'll be working with the
labs to actually get the test takers go
out take the tests and run those tests
in the labs it will take several weeks
at best this is an enormous undertaking
to go from 20 to 40 remember it took has
taken us over one month to get to where
we are today
which is on the average of 20,000 tests
per day which is the highest single
amount in the United States of America
of any state which is the a higher per
capita testing rate than any country on
the globe right so we take 20 per day
which is already an enormous ly high
number and now we want to double that
number so it's just in some ways an
outrageous goal but this is New York
from your customs outrageous goals so
it's 40 federal government will take
their piece which is the supply chain
for the national manufacturers reagents
testing kits we'll take the 300 labs and
coordinating that again it took us one
month to get to the 20,000 which is an
extraordinarily high number think about
a 20,000 tests per day
that's a system that never existed
before there was no such thing as a
covert test operation before today
before this situation the price tag it
will be expensive we don't have a price
tag we're working on estimates and
remember after the testing then you move
to tracing which is a whole different
operation of people who trace every
positive case so if you have twenty
thousand tests per day let's say the
positive is 30 percent just for kicks
that's 6,000 people per day who test
positive and you then have to trace
every one of those people to find out
who they were in contact with who did
they go to dinner with who did they in
direct contact with that they might have
infected that is just that operation is
going to be enormous seem to kind of be
doing twenty thousand a year why the
emphasis on that and not on antibody
tests boss you so both tests we have to
do both antibody tests and diagnostic
testing get up to forty thousand a day
yes I we don't know it's it's never been
done before so we said you know we're
working seven days a week 24 hours a day
but you have to assume a few weeks to
ramp it up we got to 20,000 over five
weeks just of the diagnostic now you
want to double that we need a supply
chain for the national manufacturers
which the federal government has to work
on which is an international supply
chain to get these chemicals etc and
then we have to get the labs to double
their capacity and to have test takers
out there to supply the labs with 40,000
tests per day I mean it's a enormous
undertaking you you got a commitment
President Trump to try to get to 40,000
antibody tests per day in 40,000
diagnostic and antibody come home yes
late on how exactly he'll do that if
it's a matter of the defense production
Act if it's a matter of working you know
we did not work through we didn't talk
to how he's going to do his end of the
operation but we didn't talk about how I
was gonna do my end of the operation
either remember the antibody tests the
question is what is the purpose of the
antibody tests right and it's a
different conversation on long
conversation we're not doing the largest
antibody survey in the nation it's going
on now we'll have the results in the
next couple of days what the antibody
test mines are telling you jesse is this
is the percentage of people who were
infected it could be useful as a data
point this is the percentage of people
who were infected in and recovered in
New York City in Albany and Buffalo etc
that could be helpful as a data point it
would also give you a real idea of the
mortality of this disease we know how
many people died we don't know the
denominator we don't know how many
people actually had the virus we know
how many people walked into a hospital
but that is very different than how many
people had the virus the antibody test
survey will give you the denominator
this is how many people had the virus
five percent 10 percent of the entire
population so that's a good data point
it will then tell you people who can
donate their blood for convalescent
plasma which is also good we find that
you have antibodies you can it could
also then instruct you as to who had the
disease and can go to work but let's say
a very high number let's say 10% of the
population you find with an antibody
test had had the corona virus okay
that's one point nine million people
out of a population of 19 if you tested
everybody what do you really do with
that on a practical level you know so
that's what we have to figure out just
in this cohort of 40,000 tests per day
how many of those would be diagnostic
versus we have to determine that with
the emphasis be on diagnostic or and I
think would be on diagnostic but it's a
conversation that we have to have how do
you want to use the diagnostic how do
you want to use the antibody tests
that's not speak over each other if we
can avoid it and out answer your
question as soon as I finish with the
gentleman it would be across the board
right we have some special populations
that we want to get done nursing homes
and nursing homes nursing homes and
nursing homes you have prisons you have
congregate facilities you then want
testing to find out what is the rate of
increase of the virus you're talking
about reopening and opening the opening
the valve and letting the water flow
watching the meter this is how you watch
the meter what is happening to my
infection rate so it's across-the-board
testing and then as Jesse was bringing
up part of its diagnostic part of it is
antibody testing what is the purpose of
each different type of test and how many
do you want of each that's one of the
problems with antibody testing and yeah
what is the what is the precision of the
antibody test some people have have
questioned the reliability of antibody
tests some people have questioned the
usefulness of antibody tests and then
some health officials I don't know if it
wh o said by the way just because you
have the antibodies doesn't really mean
you're immune from catching the disease
which is opposite an assumption that we
had started with putting me the first
time we did 180 degrees ice on the flip
on what we heard but if that's true then
what is the point of finding out why a
person had antibodies except to know
what the rate of spread was what a
reopening yeah the reopening has to be
on a geographic footprint that is
workable
you know downstate New York you talk
about New York City Nassau Suffolk
Westchester you make a decision anywhere
in that region that's not coordinated
you'll just see people move back and
forth you open a beach in Nassau you
don't open beaches anywhere else you'll
flood Nassau County beaches if you were
to close parks in one area open parks in
another area you can see people get in a
car and drive it's harder to do that
when you operate in a coordinated way
and that's why I've said 187 times to my
colleagues and local government they
can't be any local decisions because
they're all interconnected with everyone
else and that's also the state of the
law which says this is an emergency
the state is coordinating all decisions
yeah but that would be a real question
how would you do that and what would you
open in one region which wouldn't cause
people to flood that region that's why
it all has to be coordinated
ideally look the way we shut it down was
simple one switch everything off right
it wasn't the most sophisticated
approach but it was an emergency one
switch everything off okay so we
understand how it works on a closed-down
how do you open it up and how do you
take into consideration the fact that
western New York North Country central
New York we have a totally different
situation I mean look what you have with
the states now you have States saying I
can reopen because I don't have the
problem that New York has of California
hazard Michigan has I just have a
different situation I am a state in the
United States but I have a totally
different situation that's true I have
regions in this state that have a
totally different situation
go ask people in the north country
they'll say you know we don't have this
problem why are we closed down but
flipside your point you suffer you open
up one region they may be opening
themselves up to a problem they didn't
even understand so that's that all has
to be coordinated no one has been here
before so no one can tell you don't
worry I have the answer but think and
let's be as smart as we can in making
these decisions well you're gonna see
we'll do a financial projection in a few
days that says we're going to have to
make significant cuts to the budget
because we were all depending on federal
funding you have to remember the to the
extent I seem frustrated about this you
know why because I'm frustrated about
this we did the budget April 1 we've
been having conversations
since there started with the federal
government don't worry we're gonna fund
the state don't worry we're gonna fund
the state don't worry we're gonna fund
the state two weeks ago don't worry this
time we're really going to fund this
state don't worry the next bill zero
promise promise promise promise promise
zero not a Milch nothing zero and now
we're in a position where we have to do
a financial forecast and we have to tell
school districts you should expect a
significant cut now today again the
federal representatives say don't worry
next bill is going to have state funding
see it's not political politically sexy
for them to fund the state right when
they can do funding where they can go
hand it out to individuals and call them
up and say I got you money here it is
that is more politically appealing you
give funding to a state who who do you
call to say that who even knows nobody
it's just giving money to another
government right so I get why the Senate
does what they do I get that the Senate
also represents many states where this
is not as big a problem the federal
Senate you know you look at the map you
look at the states that are talking
about reopening they don't have the same
type of problem we do I get it but you
know I'm the governor of New York and
the senators from New York should
represent New York so well don't worry
next time I came to a budget on don't
worry next time especially after that
promise has been made and repeatedly
broken right
I'm sorry gorgeous
to send that back and also was it a good
idea to have the ship come I mean I'm
looking at numbers from yesterday
morning as of 8:00 a.m. so a little
dated but said the cumulative total
intake was 172 patients discharge was
107 the capacity for the ship was 500
and that was brought down from the yeah
so whose decision was that yours or
president Trump's to bring that [ __ ]
back and again Bernadette was it worth
it to have the comfort here it helped
172 people if you're one of those 172
people and that ship may have saved your
life they would say you're done right it
was worth it
172 people it's nothing to be trifled
with right and also if you want to look
at numbers look at the projection rates
we were dealing with Monday Morning
Quarterback is quarterbacking is what we
sort of do is a pastime the look at what
the facts were at the time look at the
numbers at the time look at the
projections that we were dealing with at
the time CDC says in March you may need
a minimum of two million hospital beds
in the nation minimum you know how many
2 million you know how many 2 million
beds are double the national capacity
that's the minimum that means in New
York we have 50,000 beds we would need
100 you can't make 50,000 beds that fast
and it's not just the CDC CDC White
House coronavirus task force Columbia
University study McKinsey study Cornell
Weill study I mean like every expert
said this is what you need we worked for
weeks day and night to get a 50,000
capacity hospital system up to about
90,000 beds we never made the projection
we never made it
even with everything we did even with
Javits even with the US Navy ship
comfort we still didn't make the
projection that every expert had said
you would need think about that thank
God
New Yorkers listened and the projection
turns out to be incorrect because we
reduced the spread of the virus with the
closings New York pause etc okay so now
the proc Shu allottee is less than the
projection did you need the beds yes
you needed the beds because that was the
projection and even with the reduced
number 172 people were in the comfort
and I believe the comfort not only
brought comfort but saved lives Javits
2,500 beds
1,200 people were in the Javits 1,200
human beings with families who received
extraordinary care because the US Army
Corps of Engineers killed themselves and
built it and because you had heroic
doctors and military doctors and staff
who staffed at 1,200 lives you know at
one time 1,200 lives were respected and
meant something and 172 lives meant
something to me they still do I know
we've lost a lot of people but every
number is a person and a family a
brother a sister
so yeah 172 people count oh I'm sorry
the topic of the ship came up I agreed
we all agreed that at this current rate
we don't need the comfort anymore and
wherever they could use it because you
do have other places in the country that
are now coming up to their curve so
whoever needs it they should have it we
sent 400 ventilators to Massachusetts
people helped us when we needed it
somebody else needs
god bless we're okay yes what did you
make the reports today out of Veterans
Hospitals then it was not effective you
had said before that there were some
anecdotal evidence to Miss Jessie I
haven't even looked at them I haven't
even gone through them I've been running
all day what the state state results
have been you said that they were being
sent to Washington yesterday I have no I
do not know I do not know which one so
[Music]
we stopped any new construction when we
saw the rate starting to stabilize but
I'm not ready to close anything down yet
either you know and look now you have
some health experts CDC today starts to
warn about an outbreak in the fall I
mean I didn't even I don't even want to
think about that yet but you know we
know this is no time to pop the
champagne bottles right I said a couple
of days ago don't get cocky don't get
arrogant anything I didn't say anything
is misstated factually okay thank you
guys
we nursing homes are private we asked
them for the information they held
liable for the veracity of the
information they sent but again we don't
write specifically the nursing homes so
over these reporting private information
private nursing home information they
send to us we give to you yes